this is where the usa meets canada and
where pandemic restrictions have met
their most costly resistance
this is usually the busiest land link
between the two countries thousands of
lorries carrying 300 million dollars of
goods each day come over this bridge
all of that shut down by this blockade
by this self-styled band of freedom
fighters
we want freedom freedom of all mandates
and that's what we're fighting for we're
canadian and we want to be free
canadians freedom of choice freedom of
choice
enough of the tyranny
are you worried about the impact this
might have on the ordinary people the
people employed by those car
manufacturing companies oh of course
it's going to impact everybody but i
think everybody should be
taking a stand and
take a week or whatever off of work and
then hopefully we can make a difference
right been here since yesterday just
yesterday at like
i think it was noon
yeah i haven't left
how long will you stay
long as it takes i guess
some have traveled here from ottawa
canada's capital has been paralyzed for
12 days now by similar protests about
vaccine and mass mandates what started
last month as a loosely organized convoy
of truckers is now this a movement which
has raised millions of dollars and
brought one of the main arteries between
the usa and canada to a complete
standstill
many here denounce the canadian prime
minister they're unlikely to listen to
his pleas to go home
individuals
are trying to blockade
our economy
our democracy
and our fellow citizens
daily lives
it has to stop
plans for more protests like this are
gaining momentum online the fear for
authorities is that this is now a
blueprint for maximum disruption
martha kellner sky news ontario canada